عالمة أنثروبولوجيا وراوية قصص بصرية
قبل عام بالضبط في الشرطي 27 الذي
حدث، جاءت سيدة أكادية أمام
الصف وتحدثت عن انضمام بحيرة تشاد الكبرى إلى ما
يقرب من 90 بالمائة منها
وكان من المهم جدًا بالنسبة لي القيام
برحلة استكشافية تحاول  اقتربت بشكل وثيق
من السكان المحليين وحاولت دراسة هؤلاء
الأشخاص وكيف تأثرت حياتهم
بهذه الأزمة.
شكلت معًا فريقًا صغيرًا
يسافر معي وقضيت 30
ليلة في خيمتي محاولًا
العيش في موقع واحد في كل مرة.  لم يكن هناك
إنترنت منفصل تمامًا عن
العالم وأركز فقط على
محيطي والأرواح التي وصلتني
طوال رحلتي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان لدي مجموعة من الأهداف طوال هذه
الرحلة وكان أحد هذه الأهداف هو المحاولة
لتقييم الوضع ومحاولة
فهم تأثير وحجم
العمل الخيري على هذا البلد بالذات
ومحاولة التوصل إلى استراتيجيات
لحل هذه المشكلة
كوني عالمة أنثروبولوجيا كان لدي مجموعة من
القبائل التي كان من المهم جدًا بالنسبة لي
العثور عليها وتعقبها  وأعيش معهم
لكتابة معلومات محدثة جديدة
وتصويرها
بشكل واضح
وأفكر حتى اللحظة التي
لن أتوقف فيها عن الشعور بالصدمة كم هو جميل
التصوير الفوتوغرافي كأداة لتجميد اللحظات
والمشاعر أعتقد أن الطفل كبلد
جميل للغاية ومع ذلك فهو
لم أكن محظوظًا بإقامة هذا الحوار
مع بقية العالم،
سيظل هذا المكان دائمًا له
مكان عظيم في قلبي
وآمل أن أعود إلى هناك مرة أخرى ربما في
وقت ما في المستقبل
[موسيقى]